puppy Harlem here none of that skank
Gloria Borger and you're watching pew
news good evening
I'm poppy Harlow and you're watching pew
knows the most reputable news source in
the planet remember ten among go
remember her Keith Smith with a
toothbrush me with a toothbrush no you
don't remember that
well she decided this she had so much
fun at the convention that she was gonna
create her own called tannic on it was
going to be the best it was you who put
this together and no disrespect to you
but like you're the last person no I
think who would arrange a conference I
couldn't a rival VidCon agree more like
I was cut to live footage of the event
I wasted a hundred and fifty dollars on
tannic on it's one hallway one big
concert room and no activities no
creators are walking around like promise
we stood outside for four hours just to
be treated like animals anything wrong
or bad or whatever if there's bad
security about it it's me it's on my
[ __ ] things they make the conference
literally so I mean I have been putting
my heart and soul into making it as
perfect as you can and no boy it was
perfect all the big celebrities we're
gonna be there as well so I mean right
now our lineup consists of so many
insane creators the ones that we have
publicly confirmed right now are along
the lines of there's so many seriously
but um me bella thorne she's doing it is
amazing ah ah Bella Thorne I never
thought I'd heard that name again that
foul Nickelodeon kid who wouldn't even
say PewDiePie's name on the Teen Choice
Awards never forgive
[Applause]
something something something you know
what be here if you want to go to the
rest of your name ah
I'm not even PewDiePie and I am super
offending she's so mean I feel bad for
feelings I know so mean why did I do
she's friends with them Tana you can't
even say her name Mungo all right who
else is gonna be there Shane Dawson we
have all of Shane's Shane okay I guess a
convention just can't be thrown in a
month not realistic
I generally support our Mungo for trying
something like this but at this point I
don't think it's safe who else made an
appearance I'm feeling an OG creep
rickey dillion who tweeted out okay
sorry jokes aside what's going on with
Tana cone I have panel at 3:00 is it
still happening so apparently they
booked a lot of people from VidCon to
come to Tanic on which you're both
happening at the same time I think
they're both in Anaheim I'm not sure I
don't care enough to find out but
apparently they they think they booked
people that were supposed to go on the
same panel at the same time over at
VidCon and Tanic on but even if they
wanted to come it was basically
impossible because it was just too much
of a mess that were supposed to be all
kinds of food at Tanner kind
oh my god that's hard everything I love
the way she eats like fried chicken I
look people tweeting out there's no food
there's no water we've been standing in
line for four hours but you know what
there was who needs food and water
especially when it's hot outside you're
standing in line with no cover you know
what you can get instead condoms that's
right not just any condoms I know it
doesn't sound that great but listen to
this it's Tanic on dumbs
my only regret in life from birth to now
is that I wasn't able to attend tannic
on where you can pay $70 to get a
conduct I like to think of it as
something younger this is a convention
for something younger here's some
condoms everybody back on ya Khan's a
good word for it first you put it at a
venue that can only hold a thousand
people max then you tell your fans
that's a gift bag it's gonna be worth
quadruple the ticket price but your gift
bag is only a smartphone grip a
wristband and a condom the only thing I
need protection from is your lies
another thing about Tana calm was that
the tickers were going to be free you
know finally convention that everyone
can enjoy very noble cause you know
perks right yeah exactly exactly we have
free admission we have a VIP featured
creator and featured King creator
because is that what it's called
featuring 15-degree yes what a feature
creators the free ticket because
everyone's a featured creator at panakam
and future Sun fader is that place yeah
yeah 100% everybody's a feature created
exactly I want that inclusivity without
feeling you know the problem is when you
make something free a lot of kids will
be there maybe too many kids then what
Dana had initially estimated this is the
meeting rate check-in line this is great
wait so you end up end up right here but
you start way back here I am Jesus
Christ so the event was too small to
hold enough people people were left
queuing outside for four hours to get in
despite even having to paid for tickets
cuz you could pay for the more exclusive
tickets but you still had to stand in
the same line as everyone else that just
came for free which then led to the
event inevitably shutting down
the whole that's for today tomorrow it's
back up and running two different venues
for more space ok what's the other venue
you know it's gonna be a night
I'm just waiting for the elements
[Music]
yelling refund givers refund this
reminds me of that Instagram model
Island convention or whatever where they
would you pay a large amount of money to
meet celebrities you're sold this ID and
then it just got out of hand or it's too
poorly managed this is certainly not the
first time a convention has gone - hey
tumbler had their own convention it the
notorious tumbler convention man had a
ball picked a ball pit what safe to say
it was a disaster now apparently they're
gonna do another two extra days to make
up for it I don't know how that's gonna
make anything better at this point
because you've already get the tanah
condom what else could you possibly want
if I got a two anaconda I would just
sleep because I that's all I want these
greedy kids just want more and more now
you may be wondering why 2/10 ado
convention why didn't you just not go to
VidCon well apparently she had a long
beef going on with VidCon she wasn't
given a featured creator pass which is
given to the people on VidCon the
creators to get special access around
the convention they can enter backstage
they get their own meet-and-greet sort
of stuff and to be fair I don't know
probably who 80 percent of these people
are I fit if I ever want to feel
disconnected from YouTube just check
who's going to VidCon and you can just
be like what these are the featured
creator oi I don't know who they are I
mean obviously some I know it feels like
the YouTube rewind videos it's not what
YouTube is it's what they want it to be
and VidCon is very you know the
pick who they want to have as a future
creator because they don't want probably
more controversial creators like ten
among go to attend their event which
leads to her coming to the event and
then fans swarming around her which
means to save the issues and she gets
kicked out and apparently this happened
year after year she got fed up why can I
just get a feature Creator pass because
I want to meet my fans so eventually she
just got fed up and she said okay I'm
gonna make my own tentacles so the whole
idea behind it I I'm totally old behind
I don't like VidCon I think it's
nightmare I think it's literally hell on
earth and I wouldn't want to go there
and especially the fact that they don't
pay anyone to go there the whole premise
of VidCon is that you get to meet
youtubers that's why people are paying
$200 for tickets and none of that goes
to the actual thing that drives for the
sales of the tickets and it's kind of
like it's this weird guilt thing where
oh you're not going to VidCon well then
you don't care about meeting your fans
when clearly youtubers are just being
used by these companies but then again
VidCon does offer a venue for you to
meet your fans in a safe environment or
at least that's how they say it is but
there's yet to be an influence or really
doing like a big American like in
California a convention with oh why not
these big you ever no one's not I don't
know what I don't know what let me
explain why because it's really hard to
pull up a convention I think every
single convention their first one has
been a disaster because you need that
experience you need to build it
successively is that what it's called
so technically every single year and
make it bigger and bigger and bigger you
can't just immediately jump to 15,000
people you got to start where we are
very small and if you sell tickets on
the premise that it's gonna be free
obviously if people didn't even get the
tickets they're gonna show up anyway
which is what happened and he got out of
control so I hope she takes whatever she
learned even though I mean this whole
thing and she does it next year and
maybe name it something like started so
long VidCon it's been real
this is the reason why I don't want to
go to VidCon people screaming at you is
just obnoxious
there's no reason no reason why anyone
should treat me more than anyone else I
don't want it I find it annoying if I
can't talk to another person without
them getting past the barrier that
somehow I'm a big youtuber then I don't
want to talk to that person is this a
waste of time
I hate promoting this whole idea that
you have to act all cuz this is talk
behavior this is not in our DNA that we
should somehow react this way for people
that we think is celebrities it's just
so idiotic I hate this whole concept of
Fame and worship why why is that a thing
same reason I don't like getting
recognized a lot of times anymore
because people just start screaming and
they make a big scene and I'm just
they're like why are you yelling just
stop I just now I don't want to be here
if people meet up and just talk like a
normal person it's so much more pleasant
and it's just fun and it's just cool and
I hate how this whole idea of worship is
being promoted through this VidCon
events where people just run around like
a Neanderthal and yelling because they
saw someone famous and they hope to see
someone famous on YouTube this is so
stupid
I hate it call your conventions that was
a lot of time on one topic Felix yes it
I mean papi yes it was moving on however
to the next story the World Health
Organization included gaming disorder as
the latest version in its disease
classification manual we talked about
this before but now it's finally been
made official World Health Organization
whu-oh has announced gaming disorder is
a thing it's a real thing now I'm kind
of on the fence on this I don't really
know where I stand to be honest I really
do see both sides a lot of people are
questioning this move scientist
specifically saying there was lack of
good quality scientific evidence about
how to properly diagnose video game
addiction also arguing the point that
we're essentially pathologizing a hobby
it's next tanning addiction dance
addiction exercise addiction but no one
is having a conversation about that and
I kind of I really do understand this
point why is gaming specifically being
targeted here it seems like it's just a
very popular topic right now but why is
gaming getting taken the whole beating
essentially it's an addiction yeah but
why is gaming disorder a thing I was
heavily addicted I've no doubt about
that
I just I denied it for many many years
you know saying that oh yeah I really
need it when I travel away it's so
important whereas I wasn't sort of
really confronting the real issue itself
so what the world champion winner of
snooker says he was addicted that's how
he got world champion you could say that
anyone that tries to get an Olympic
medal or you just you're just addicted
to training you're training every single
day you don't even let them have games
at all I have so far managed to resist
all they are six and eight but I I
really did question the how sensible it
is to invite something that we know is
very addictive computer games are very
addictive so with fortnight getting so
popular especially with young kids a lot
of parents are discussing this right now
as well it's obviously a very popular
topic this woman saying that she doesn't
even let her kids play video games at
all and she sort of says it proudly as
well and I'm not a parent I don't know
what that's what it's like to raise kids
and make them follow your lead but I
think disallowing kids from doing
something that probably everyone in
their school is doing it's a terrible
idea and I guarantee you these kids are
sneaking out to just play with friends
and such instead and I think from
personal experience that if you're not
allowed to play video games you're going
to overcompensate that at a certain
point hello everybody
PewDiePie here I personally wasn't
allowed to play video games as much as I
wanted to when I grew up I think if
anything he just took me longer to
realize myself that I don't want video
games to be the main focus in my life
because I wasn't allowed to
as much as I wanted it sort of made it
like it turned into all the focus even
when I wasn't playing so it really
didn't make any difference but then
again you have people on the complete
other end of the spectrum where people
are dying from gaming benches girls as
young as nine it has to go to rehab
because they wet themselves from to keep
playing obviously you can be addicted to
anything and people do get addicted to
gaming classifying it as a disorder
however specifically Gaming disorder I
don't know if that's necessarily helpful
I think the most effective thing would
be to teach kids okay work first play
later at least that's what I would do if
I had kids I know I asked this question
last episode but I think teaching kids
that attitude at a young age okay fine
you can play video games you can do
whatever you want as long as you do you
your work first right makes sense right
I don't know I'm talking like it's as if
I know everything about parenting
clearly I don't what do you think leave
a comment down below and let me know
that was oddly sexual the final new
whose his sister random me all he needs
to tag is hash tag black ops 4 and hash
tag Call of Duty partner and the rest
can be his works Call of Duty why don't
you pay me I promise you I can do better
but whatever I have to do a sponsor
tweets that client always sends like
okay can you do this sort of wording and
I always change it up completely because
I don't want it to sound like I'm a
robot or I am I am a lawyer or it's
someone completely different
but diandra eight and he really took it
to the next level this is not the first
time this has happened we have a dish on
can you please tweet this for ESP wise
party for tonight chilling at the ESP
Weiss Nakia pre-party it's awesome
or this dude on Instagram excited to
head to City and join the team name
diandra deleted it and tried again
awesome time yesterday with the hashtag
blackhat for crew thanks for having me
hashtag call of duty partner meanwhile
I'm promoting games everybody thank you
that were said for pew news hope you
guys enjoyed watching if you did leave a
like and really appreciate it these
episodes do get by the YouTube ad system
so please any support that you can give
I highly appreciate now my state this
has been poppy Harlow poppy out
[Music]